yeah to this day I go off energy a lot
so something felt wrong and my Dad loved
him so much like he was about to pay a
500 I was like No And I stopped my dad
from paying because I knew I would never
forgive myself if he paid 100 for this
scam which I knew it was a scam already
so he walked out of there and I was like
Dad I was like no I was like no no it's
a bit of that like it's not real and
he's like oh okay because my dad was
just gonna pay for whatever I want you
know what I mean and it was really sweet
and like I remember that day I was like
oh my gosh she believes in me like he
wants me to do this and it was like the
encouragement which cut to you know
doing a movie in Canada was my first
time in Canada he felt ill because how
old were you this was not that long ago
this one like five years ago oh wow and
uh I was doing a film there and my dad
fell ill because he'd been smoker his
whole life and he was in the hospital
but my mom didn't tell me because he
didn't want to bother me at work and so
he'd been in the hospital for like a
month and so I would call and like say
how you doing he like pretended he was
okay and then I got back uh home and
literally it was heartbreaking before I
got there I was like just let you know
he's been in the hospital I was like Mom
why don't you tell me he's like because
he didn't want you to fly back home and
worry about it and I was like okay
that's ridiculous I would have left that
movie it was like stupid you know what I
mean and I just like got back and went
to the hospital it was like July I think
second and I saw him at the hospital I
was like oh yeah they put me all this
stuff it's fine I'm gonna be fine I was
like okay Dad and I was like okay we'll
see you tomorrow like okay and then he
passed away that night and I was just
like he waited till I got home to say
goodbye and I was just like and he was
he was the best dad and so I miss
entirely but he totally believed in me
so I hope he's really proud of the work
that I've done isn't isn't that most of
it when someone that you love and look
up to
um
supports you and what you want to do
yeah and gives you unconditional love
and says if that's what you want I mean
there's nothing better no it really does
make a huge difference you know it does